also es gibt halt mega viele level aber
es würde keinen sinn ergeben weil wir
wollen ja eigentlich nur noch ein
bisschen feiern weil gut genug
ausgerüstet sind
hallo bist du dir sogar den niederrhein
menschen
ich bin aber bei minecraft war oh hallo
also ich finde den zurzeit recht
unterhaltsam was hinter sei nicht witzig
ich finde das gut geschnitten auf jeder
hier diese fitness leute da applaudiert
sie hatte ich stark bin ich in stroh
eine zweite karriere sexuell attraktiver
tracks auf diesen wieder bei sarow und
leute wir sind inzwischen so verzweifelt
weil es sind ja mega viele leute also in
den letzten folgen und tagen sind ja
einfach am laufenden band teams und
menschen und sonstige personen gestorben
und menschen mit tricks teams und beate
teams sind für mich keine menschen wir
sind eine symbiose eine neue lebensform
und applikationen von unseren
eigentlichen gesellschaftlichen ableiten
das hast du wunderschön gesagt da merkt
man dass du gerade im abi stress und das
haben jetzt getan luca was was hast du
was hast du wieder in die kunden
geschrieben also ja ich habe einfach 23
folgen haben ja ich irgendwann unter der
erde sowie die zehn folgen dafür auch
und da haben wir einmal das thema
angeschnitten warum sind eigentlich wir
immer nur allein auf dem sie mit welchen
anderen weil wir waren glaube ich nur am
anfang und das war es dann auch schon
mal drauf als andere leute auch drauf an
auch zwischendurch kamen als zweiter nur
wo wir in direkten kontakt mit leuten
waren und
damals halt gefragt woran liegt das und
es liegt einfach daran das denke ich die
leute immer mehr respekt vor uns haben
weil die einzigen
ich will jetzt nicht zu weit spoiler die
folge kommenden morgen es sind schon
wieder ein paar leute gestorben so weit
kann ich ja schon mal sagen ich will ich
sagen wer aber es gibt nur noch drei
teams nehmen uns das ist jetzt kein
spoiler das ist ja einfach eine tatsache
da könnt ihr jetzt nicht sagen dass
gestoppt deswegen es gibt nur noch ganz
ganz wenig spieler
wir sind schon unter unserem unter dem
ziel das wir uns am anfang gesetzt haben
also die rangliste dingsbums da und
deswegen wollen jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen action action ball will ich
haben schon
wir haben jetzt ich sag mal so wenn wir
sterben würden wäre es nicht so schlimm
dass wir sagen würden ja kraft danach
wieder zwei monate keine videos weil er
kein projekt hat oder so wir haben da
schon hat geplant was cool ist hiernach
ich bin jetzt übrigens gerade wieder
mittel soll ich mir einfach im netz
irgendwie gucken muss ich weiß nich
willst wollen wir vielleicht erst mal
wieder werden auch geschrieben man so
nachschauen und während gerade getrennt
rum dass es nicht nur die schlauer ja
ich wollte dir kann mich sehr wundert
einen fährt und was mir was mir gerade
auch aufgefallen ist
ich war eigentlich richtig ruhe weil wir
es wert sich umgezogen und dann hätte
eigentlich herausfinden können wo unsere
basis ist
ich war heute einfach eine lehre tue tue
protected einfach gelebt ruhe protected
das heißt man hätte zu uns kommen können
unter das alles weg luton und es wäre
komplett meine schuld gewesen und da hat
es mich auf jeden gast
er ist ja schön nicht passiert ist es
macht mir mal wie mache ich mir ein
sattel
den musst du finden in dungeons glaube
ich oder oder ist das nicht so soll ich
jetzt mal so könnten sondern uns in der
mitte treffen oder oder oder wie sie es
bis in der mitte am hellen dass männer
mit lass einfach mal ein bisschen
rumlaufen und so ok also derweil der
zweite interessen machen 200.000.000
sattel sattel minecraft tut mir ganz
klar bei twitter gefragt nee du
arschloch kann man sich das schon
erwähnten spiel aber das war einfach ein
pferd kann man sich nicht mehr kann man
sich nicht kaufen
ich weiß gar nicht was ich alles
mitnehmen will ich packen wir mal 30
kräften bisschen was mit einem hier
reisen waren habe ich aber nicht
mitnehmen gold apfel machen kann zwar
den apfel dabei bringen wir allgemein
mal bitte also mit eisen
ja heißen eisen solche mitbringen ja und
bei 0 0 ist irgendwo ja das ist eine
riesige säule da können uns mal treffen
also noch ein paar verletzt dann kann es
vielleicht pferde holen ja ich habe auch
zuckerrohr dabei du hast ja gesagt das
hast du noch leder oder sowas 11 leder
habe ich okay dann habe ich noch zwei
rädern dass ich das mal da drin weil
ichs grad eben was ich was ich mitnehmen
was du für mich im üblichen abgucken
ich nehme mich in spa hat mag ich nicht
die ganzen pilzsuppe ihm ein hund rastet
sich da unten gerade im 1 ab das ist
nicht zu fassen
wahrscheinlich kommt gerade meine
familie heim das heißt wenn ihr gleich
unten schüsse hört von wegen gar nicht
warum du bist eine enttäuschung
sondergleichen
ich sehe ein haus mit leiterin ich weiß
gar nicht was ich genommen so luca was
soll ich denn mitnehmen gibt norden
fährt das wichtigste mit watte wills
moment moment ganz ruhig kinos ja du
warten ganz kurzfristig muss man ganz
kurz ihre neue platte ich komme einfach
kurz zu dir ich bin ja gar nicht mal so
weit von hat sich ganz so einfach kurz
zu mir kommen und gucken was da sinnvoll
ist das auch mit zu nehmen wir haben
auch noch einmal nach diamanten
da bekommt er eine diamant schaufel
machen dass wir dinge oder wird doch
super des bonner jeweilige spot diamant
schaufel war supergeil richtig schön
dann wird man jemanden effizient genutzt
und die sache ist auch wir haben ich
habe vor zehn minuten geschrieben
die jungs kommen office server und ist
immer noch keine antwort gekommen sieht
nicht sieht nicht so aus als hätte
irgendjemand hier findest du dann zurück
zu unserer basis ich finde auf jeden
fall zurück du ich hab weil ich habe ja
auch sagen dass du dann plant und hin
muss in den dms umgezogen ja ich bin in
der letzten folge habe ich nichts
anderes getan als unser zeug umzuziehen
oder weg zu bringen wo anders hin
spannung spannung ich kann ich kann ich
kann ich auch einfach mal suchen also
bestimmt irgendwie merkmal die colt die
koordinaten ich bin gerade auf dem weg
zu der basis wo wir sind ihr sehr viele
mods eigentlich gucken ob ich dich
einfach finden wir laufen aber er steht
einfach mal seinen zauber tisch in der
landschaft herum auch ohne schlecht
scherzte ist natürlich auch dabei gut
ich hab alles dabei und zu verzaubern im
nun frau
jetzt nicht wir haben mehr zauberin die
haben mehr zauber tischer als gieriger
alle kinos ja ja wo bist du denn ich
hoffe es einfach mal richtung mitte okay
also sagen wir mal deine koordinaten
sollte kriegst du ja ist eigentlich egal
das haus zu piepsen oder scheiß drauf
euromaxx - 350 okay ich laufe einfach zu
ihr okay und z 180 - 350 und z hatte -
350 bist du gerade noch in die falsche
richtung nachfrage nix 400 und cx - 400
und 200 400 und 200 okay wir finden uns
bestimmt irgendwann wieder irgendwo her
müssten ich suche einfach irgendwo
eventuell ich bin schon wieder bei
seiner schwulen blumenwiese wir finden
aber ich habe jetzt stimmt ich kann mir
die koordinaten unserer basis
aufschreiben dann finden wir schon
wieder zucker
es ist doch irgendwie immer trauriger
wenn man jetzt so oft hat man weiß dass
immer weniger leute hier drauf von one
sind wir bei einer die einzigen hier
sind über xing und gar kein kanzler
wickelte weiter so wie neulich jemand in
den kommentaren der mich gefragt wann
ich dann endlich mal wieder hero
aufnehmen
projekt mit dezent vorbei kann man kann
man auf den server noch drauf existiert
und ich habe ein letztes mal probiert
ich hab aber auch mein headset
gelöschten wollte damit er noch mal ein
micro kind deshalb vielleicht auch nicht
so wahrscheinlich eher weniger ja genau
dass ich habe jetzt einfach mal in
unsere hero konto was rein geschrieben
hast da sind aber nur noch kev und ich
glaube ich auch dass zug drin gewesen
gew alle anderen aus geekelt hatten ja
statt blau stadlau hat sich verstritten
die bei gute zeiten schlechte zeiten
das war toll dass ich das wollte war so
schade dass wir eigentlich nicht so viel
da irgendwie zusammen gemacht haben im
nachhinein ist wir waren die einzige
stadt vor gar kein zusammenhalt geht ja
ja da als ich dann am 20 januar
abgespaltet wir haben einen über grund
gegründet
das ist irgendwie recht schnell
auseinander gegangen das stimmt zwar
echt traurig fußball ganz traurig das
hab ich auch meine mama keine unterhosen
wenn die jemals sich die folgen anschaut
wundert sich auch das ist nebenbei
fertig lauf so was war denn die falsche
richtung aber ich müsste du müsstest
wann bist du denn jetzt gleich beide
seiten - 500 vix angeht und z400 du
wolltest bei z wurde zum 200 ich bin
aber den koordinaten mit seinem schaaf
muss danach mal würde ich sagen werde
damit ein bisschen schneller unterwegs
sind wenn wir die welt zu müssen
hingegen gar nix irgendwie bringt
überhaupt nichts
ich guck mal hier bei twitter
kollidieren sachen schreiben hat hier so
viele team
alles sachen die wir halt schon tausend
mal hatten
was ist euer ziel bei faro ist schon
längst über schoss vorbei ist vorbei
meint so schlechten meilen über meilen
das ist unglaublich lichtjahre davon
entfernt also im positiven bereich video
day einfach www.wiwo.de video day.de wir
haben gesagt das kann man mal kurz
erwähnen wir haben am anfang in den
ersten gang sagt der so top 3 die erste
folge überleben war das erste ziel
ja da bist du übrigens 100 m protein
nach danach kam das ziel ja wir können
aber irgendwie top 30 und einmal das auf
top 20 angehoben soll's absolutes
absolutes ende der fahnenstange wir uns
gedacht haben dass wir der krasseste
steht wenn wir das hinkriegen
und jetzt sind wir anderen in der top 15
das musste sich auf der zunge zergehen
das finde ich sagen ich weiß nicht
willkommen zu diesem zeitpunkt wie viele
tode da schon feststellen
die meisten die meisten stehen fest also
das ist wir beraten ja auch nicht wer
oder was
und in dem sinne kein spoiler deswegen
wir sind auch immer sehr vorsichtig
verliert dieses spiel reizwort einziges
team mehr oder weniger würde ich sogar
sagen erkennen es ist pvp und wie geht
extrem vorsichtig vor bevor wir in
andere kämpfe gehen und so wir versuchen
hier keine spoiler auszutreten und alles
möglich also da intern gibt es
diskussionen dass das was ich gemacht
habe falsche war obwohl es wirklich ein
pvp projekt ist und als ich dann in der
basis von java die joy also das einzige
team in dem sinne patrick hat ja auch
ist ja auch wirklich pvp aggressiv
vorgegangen
und es ist so geil von der community ist
ein vielleicht zwei eisenbahn geben zwei
wochen kommt kommt es gibt aber mal die
hälfte vermeiden bitte schön dass der 32
damit so dass ich genug anfangen lassen
denke ich doch mal steht dass man sich
so im sattel machen kann aber kann man
sich gar nicht
ich glaube da muss man nicht finden also
wenn ich wenn ich mich recht wir haben
ja auch mega viele pferde
ja aber ich will es ist echt würdig
wären wir haben diesmal ich verstehe das
nicht wieso denn jetzt niemand nach das
ist doch wir sind doch gerade
frischfleisch schlechthin
schade aber hat jedoch ich will dieses
weiße haus ja und da hinten ist doch so
ein braunes
dieses irgendwie kalt in meinem zimmer
mein unterleib zittert schon wieder
junge ist richtig kalt ist richtig schön
war mir ja ja genau dann war es dass wir
jetzt ein bisschen ähnlich hohe dass man
also der umgebung ich immer ein bisschen
durch durch die wut oder noch eine falle
von early bei dass wir auch ganz schön
wir brauchen aber ohne sprache und
angefangen zu duschen
also ich schneide das nach einer
nachschau stellten der mitte mein freund
sagt die mitte gefunden wo bist du komm
komm komm mal in die mitte ja gut so
einfach zu -150 z 30 oder so dann sieht
es schon und dann ist da die mitte und
da ist auch der friedhof wo die
bisherigen toten stehen und wir könnten
jetzt natürlich auch die hölle gehen
wollen einfach mal eine hölle gehen
ich weiß nicht also dass weg wie canvas
ist die lage ja natürlich aber ich hätte
auch richtig gerne sondern einfach mal
so ein bisschen mehr abenteuer weiss
hasler abenteuer des bottroper am
mittelpunkt kommt kommst du denn
entgegen
ja du ich bin auf dem weg gehen will mir
kommen ja auch gar keine max entgegen
oder sowas ja mir kommt glaubt mega viel
entgegen irgendwie kommt auch mega viel
an gegen das auch ironisch von mir das
ist richtig viel was mir entgegenkommt
kommt dann schließlich jetzt mal ein
bisschen erstmal ein bisschen regen
humorvoll machen und dann sehen wir den
zombies damals sikorski kombiniert eine
leder richtung dabei hallo hallo gehts
also mit einer kurzen momente angst
gemacht der mit einem schlag ins gesicht
sei das war zuerst ich habe nämlich nur
gehirne 31
gebratenem hühnchen aber ich geb dir mal
die hälfte davon noch ein bisschen was
gebraten ist davon habe ich schon
gedacht wir können sie erst mal kurz mal
die spiele weg locken und schöne tier 1
rennen ich bin so gilt im pvp oh mein
gott ja gut wollen wir so eine
geschützte chastain bauen hier sind ja
auch gar keine vielen träumen unsere
unsere jazz ist ja protect in der base
logischerweise unsere wichtigen items in
kuba sind die ganzen julis friedhof des
friedens das ist poly kronen das glaub
ich mache ja ich glaube schon hier liegt
shuttle lpd not im baum liegen
eigentlich dumm und stege in einem
gemeinsamen grab hier irgendwie weithin
bauen oder so können gab ihn bauen und
schreiben hier liegt kontrabass unschuld
jungfräulichkeit jungfräulichkeit oder
oder die halle ist reizt es reizt mich
schon also es gibt halt mega viele level
aber es würde keinen sinn ergeben weil
wir wollen ja eigentlich nur noch ein
bisschen warten weil gut aufgestellt
sind
hallo bist du dir den rhein menschen ich
bin aber kritisch steht einfach direkt
zu 2000 verdammten leuten
es komme ich komme direkt nach kiefer
ich hab den erfolg erzielt keine karte
verließen keine für diesen pigments
angreifen ja weil die böden schon krasse
erfahrung geben ja aber du kriegst auch
krasse erfahrung einfach durch wir
müssen auch gucken dass er wieder
zurückfinden deswegen mache jetzt mal
hier die koordinaten auf damit ich mir
die nachher abgucken kann falls wir
nicht finden sollten dass irgendwo ein
gast ich höre und gast durch die kirche
einfach war schon mal rein geschrieben
ist damit weiterhin einen glas durch die
gegend watson wo man lang heißt das
spannenden conny es ist ein richtiges
abenteuer etwas öfter für die nicht
treffen aller diesen mega sieht die
mamis damage das war einfach ein
bisschen lang laufen
was ist da unten lava ich hab' ich hab'
ich hab so angst dass version
langweiliger tot
dadurch ich weiss nicht ober boxern
pitman anzugreifen einfach nein da
greifen uns alle an
eine festung suchen oder mal ein
bisschen abenteuer hier unten ist
irgendwas da ist ja eine festung oder
sowas
wo ist dieser scheiß gastmann das macht
etwa keine sorgen macht mir ich mal mit
megaphon bin seitdem unser ziel über
schossen bin ich einfach so zum auto
unterwegs sparen ja ich mehr als nur
ungleich fenster runter und dann ist es
vorbei dann kannst du dich nicht die
festung und von der festung auch schon
daran glaube ich gop und zum ewigen
zeiten durch die gegend hüpft wie so
fest sondern auch super super super
einfach eine neue festung ja die
barriere oder sind da zehnte richtige
hüttenabend hier wo bist du denn mal auf
die ganzen weg zu können man zusammen
auch hier rumlaufen man so ein bisschen
rumlaufen sehe ja auch kein gas menschen
ich lege aber auch kein gas ist doch
kein gas würde die folge ja dass hier
kein gas ist aber sauer richtig toll wir
sind wieder zu hause glaube ich habe ja
wenn's hoch kommt durch wieder einen
pokal oder so ich sehe diese diese dinge
gefunden haben hier richtig schön durch
die gegend spielen angreifen nicht so
schwer sein
ich sehe es komme ich glaube dann
attackieren einfach alle dann haben hier
mega stress in der hütte willst du mega
stress ist optimist mega stress oder
hey ich hab ein bogen ich habe sowas
feile mich super gefühlt weil er ist ja
wir haben noch 30 sekunden
okay wir sind gerade bei 15 minuten 13 3
gekommen bin jetzt schon raus über die
folge häufig gefallen hat und wenn ihr
wollt dass wir ein bisschen abenteuer
reich sondern lasst eine positive
bewertung darunter abenteuer reiches